while Pokemon Legends Arceus dipped its
toes in what an open world Pokemon game
could be Pokemon scarlet and violet
fully embrace it this new approach to
the tried and true Pokemon formula
reinvigorates the mainline series and
delivers one of the most challenging and
rewarding Pokemon Adventures today
[Music]
whoever is in
inner progression
scarlet and violet make some subtle
efforts to guide you to specific
locations but ultimately how you forge
your own path through the vibrant new
region of paldea is what makes it so
memorable scarlet and violet starts off
like most Mainline Pokemon games you
wake up at home meet your rival pick one
of three starters and before long you're
exploring the world and catching a wide
range of monsters while the tutorial
might still feel a bit overbearing for
longtime fans it moves at a Brisk Pace
before long nimona your Pepe battle
hungry rival turns you loose and you're
free to explore a hefty chunk of the map
battle trainers at your discretion and
catch wild Pokemon it does slow down a
bit as it introduces characters and the
three main quest lines but soon after
that you are free to explore paldea in
its entirety scarlet and violet strength
lies in their freedom and that freedom
extends Beyond its open world at the
outset you are given three different
paths to follow the path of Legends
which has you hunt down and defeat
abnormally large Pokemon on operation
Starfall where you deal with this
generation's Team Rocket and the
familiar Victory Road in which you take
on eight gym leaders unlike previous
games there is no predetermined path
through the story although trainers and
wild Pokemon get tougher the further you
get from Mesa goza paldea Center most
City there's nothing outright stopping
you from marching up to one of the
toughest gym leaders in the game and
challenging them to a battle in fact
Pokemon scarlet and violet doesn't even
tell you how tough a specific area is
until you're actually there that lack of
transparency may seem odd in a
level-based RPG but it encouraged me to
travel off the beaten path and scout out
areas a traditional Pokemon game would
have gated off the lack of Random
Encounters also Fosters this type of
exploration Pokemon are crawling over
every square inch of the map palmy the
adorable new electric type rodent
travels in packs psyduck's will saunter
through Fields occasionally taking a dip
in a nearby stream and peaches can often
be found napping under Shady trees like
in Arceus I often found myself chasing
new Pokemon I spotted off in the
distance until I ended up in an area I
wasn't quite ready for occasionally
these spontaneous Adventures would end
with a team wipe but sometimes I'd walk
away with a powerful new Pokemon to join
my roster in many ways it feels like
game freak has finally taken the
training wheels off of Pokemon
throughout my adventure I felt like I
was constantly punching above my weight
against Gym Leaders Titan Pokemon and
team star bosses in most cases my
Pokemon were lower levels than the
competition which forced me to think
Beyond The Familiar rock paper scissors
type matchups Nature's abilities
handheld items things I rarely consider
during a Pokemon game's main story would
often give me enough of an edge to
narrowly beat a trainer I would have
otherwise lost to terastalizing adds
another wrinkle to the challenge most
key trainers you go toe-to-toe with Will
terastalize their final Pokemon which
can alter a Pokemon's typing every
Pokemon in the paldeo region has a Terra
type along with its standard type or
types however some Pokemon you come
across will have a Terra type different
from their standard type for example the
grass type gym leader brassius uses the
rock type Pokemon sudowuru but his
sudowuru has the graster type once this
Sudowoodo terastalizes the water or
grass type attacks you'd usually use
against the pseudowoodu won't be very
effective most Gym Leaders use
terastalizing to cover their weaknesses
making the final push a tad more
difficult if you aren't prepared or
under leveled of course you don't have
to play scarlet and violet the same way
I did you can seek out challenges you
are appropriately leveled for and stick
to safer areas while you train this
approach is still far more compelling
than the traditional Pokemon structure
because there are plenty of areas to
explore a wide variety of Pokemon to
catch and a handful of main objectives
to complete wherever you choose to go
know and even when I was under leveled
for some of the tougher points of
interest I rarely felt like my only
option was to grind out Levels by
repeatedly battling wild Pokemon
grinding is far less tedious than it
used to be thanks to the let's go
mechanic this allows the first Pokemon
in your party to Auto Battle wild
Pokemon Auto battling doesn't net you as
much experience as a standard battle but
because Auto battles are decided within
a few seconds you can battle a high
volume of Pokemon in a short amount of
time Auto battling also ties into TM
crafting unlike in previous games once
you find or receive a TM you can craft
copies of it at Pokemon centers
when you knock out a wild Pokemon it
drops crafting materials and you can
earn those crafting materials far more
efficiently by Auto battling however
while Auto battles make TM crafting much
easier than it would be otherwise I'd
much prefer an option to buy the ones I
want all TMS require components from
specific Pokemon meaning that you have
to make an effort to track down that
Pokemon and battle it a few times the
good news is that you can swap out your
Pokemon's moves at any time if you
accidentally replace the move you can go
into the Pokemon summary menu and
relearn it this is also true for TMS if
you use a TM on a Pokemon that move will
always be available in its move pool
it's a small change but a welcome one
that makes it much easier to experiment
with move sets on the Fly it's hard to
discuss the competitive scene without
touching on battling terastalizing will
certainly shake things up but it's
difficult to say exactly how at this
stage in theory a competitive team could
cover far more weaknesses thanks to this
mechanic with six Pokemon to a team and
potentially three different types per
Pokemon each Pokemon standard two types
and a third different Terra type you
could represent all 18 types in one
party My Hope Is it will result in a far
more diverse lineup of viable
competitive Pokemon and new inventive
strategies since typing is such an
important part of the team building
process as excited as I am to test out
these strategies scarlet and violet lack
a battle tower there are some exciting
post-game challenges but the absence of
a proper battle tower makes it very
difficult to experiment with different
teams and test out new strategies in a
low stakes competitive environment the
omission of the battle tower is likely
due to scarlet and Violet's expanded
Suite of online features unfortunately
as of now the servers aren't live yet so
I haven't been able to test online
battles cooperative play link trades and
surprise trades of these I am most
curious to see what Co-op adds to the
package could you potentially play
through the entire game with a few
friends or is it it limited to basic
exploration if Co-op manages to capture
the same sense of Freedom as the single
player it could be a fantastic way to
play these games the level of Freedom
found in scarlet and violet comes at a
significant cost though particularly in
their presentation these games look
rough there's a moment early on where
you follow your rival to the top of a
lighthouse whether intentional or not it
feels like it's supposed to be that
moment in every open world game where
you can appreciate the vast expanse of
the world before you unfortunately the
muddy visuals undercut the moment Mesa
goza looks like a collection of
off-white shapes in the distance the
trees look more like green blobs than
trees and the rotating Pokeball above
the Pokemon Center moves at only a few
frames per second while the Pokemon and
key characters are well rendered not
much else is textures are missing
objects in the distance are pixelated in
jittery Pokemon and NPCs are constantly
popping in and out due to poor draw
distances and battles on uneven terrain
will frequently cause the camera to clip
through the ground between Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 and Bayonetta 3 the switch
has really shown its age this year but
Pokemon scarlet and violet feel as
though they are being crushed by the
hardware Pokemon Legends Arceus had its
fair share of visual shortcomings but
not to this extent whether you play
handheld or docked Pokemon scarlet and
violet are difficult on the eyes
fortunately scarlet and violet run
pretty well don't expect a buttery 60
frames per second but during my time
with the games I haven't experienced any
slowdowns or significant dips to the
frame rate of course a game like Pokemon
doesn't demand Rock Solid performance
but it is comforting to see that despite
all of the visual rough patches
performance holds up decently while
undercooked presentation and visuals
hold the game back Pokemon scarlet and
violet are still the best Mainline
Pokemon games in years they build off
Pokemon Legends arceus's open-ended
design and some thoughtful and
surprising ways and retain that same
level of depth that the mainline series
is known for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]